Welcome students
to the pharmacology
of the non-steroidal anti
-inflammatory
drugs, the NSAIDs.
This first part
of the lecture
is in two
different videos.
Part 1A is the
biochemistry and physiology
background that you
need to understand in
order to be able to
understand the NSAIDs.
The second video
is the class
effects of this
group of drugs.
The part two is
another separate
video that will go
into the individual
drugs. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
Please contact
me if you'd like
to chat about
pharmacology.
The learning objectives
are here. I have
given them headings
so that you can easily
see at a glance what
you need to know.
And I have my usual
materials for
you and links.
And I do want to stop
here for a moment and
talk about some study
hints. I always recommend
to first get the big
picture, the class
effects. all of the
drugs are going to be
falling into this big
class they will have these
effects now the individual
drugs may differ
in some way but for the
purposes of learning
for being efficient
with your learning if
you get the big picture
first then all you
need to do when you
get to the drug names
the individual drugs,
let's see how they're
different. And that
will condense the amount
of material that you
feel you have to learn.
Number one though,
become familiar with
the physiologic foundation
of pharmacology.
That is true for
all pharmacology.
Key points are on this
one slide. This one
slide covers everything
that I'll be talking
about in these two in
introductory videos.
So part 1a, the
biochemistry of arachidonic
acid, the biosynthesis
of prostanoids,
and their physiologic
effects. So
first some definitions,
the language of
pharmacology, the
language of medicine.
Eicosanoids are
products of arachidonic
acid metabolism.
These are a very large
family of signaling
molecules, and I'll go
through the pathways
briefly for you.
And prostanoids, this
is our focus, is a
subclass of the
eicosanoids consisting of
the prostaglandins,
and I've listed them
here. You should be
familiar with them.
Prostacycline,
which is PGI2.
I'll be referring
to it both ways.
And thromboxane,
I left off the A2.
Thromboxane A2, TXA2.
So, big picture,
prostanoid mediators
are derived from
arachidonic acid and
sites of drug action.
And I have the
sites of drug action
also on this chart.
So, arachidonic acid,
let's begin with that.
It is a lipophilic,
hydrophobic molecule
that's present in the
intracellular membranes
of the nuclear
endoplasmic reticulum
complex. That's where
it's located, and it's
part of the lipid
bilayer of that membrane.
So it just sits there
until it's activated.
So chemical and physical
stimuli activate,
first of all, phospholipase
A2, which then
hydrolyzes the membrane
phospholipids where
arachidonic is, and
that will release the
arachidonic acid. And
I put a little reminder
sketch of the lipid
bilayer of the membranes.
Looking now on the right
-hand side in this figure,
here's the stimulus.
I mentioned some
kind of stimulus.
The disturbance
of the cell
membranes and the
phospholipids.
And here is
arachidonic acid.
Now, there are
several pathways.
I should say there are
several final products
at the end of
different pathways. And
each of them has some
function in terms of
the usually inflammatory
process. But it's
more complicated than
that. But for our
purposes, we're thinking
about inflammation.
I have circled here
on the right-hand
side the cyclooxygenase
prostanoid
pathways that are
the target of the
NSAIDs. And here's
our NSAID right here.
In other lectures,
you will be learning
about these other drugs
that are indicated in
these white boxes,
but not this lecture.
Arachidonic acid is
metabolized by
cyclooxygenases,
2-prostacyclin,
thromboxane, and
prostaglandins.
And then, these all
have different
functions, which I
will go into in a
different slide.
Now, an up-close
look, here's our
arachidonic acid
sitting in the membrane,
being released by
phospholipase A2.
And then, here's
the arachidonic
acid. You can
see it's a lipid
molecule, it's
hydrophobic.
It can undergo
metabolism by the
cytochrome P450 system
and become signaling
molecules. It can
be metabolized by
the lipoxygenase
pathway and become
signaling molecules,
different ones.
This is the pathway
we are interested
in, the cyclooxygenase
pathway, where they
become prostaglandins,
prostacyclin,
and thromboxane,
known as prostanoids.
So, prostanoid
biosynthesis, what is
happening? Here's our
arachidonic acid again.
Here are the two types
of cyclooxygenases.
The arachidonic acid
is metabolized to
this product, known
as PGG2. and then it
undergoes another
metabolism, peroxidase,
and it now produces PGH2.
Neither of these
are functional as
signaling molecules.
They are intermediates.
PGH2 now with specific
synthases will
form all of the
different prostanoids.
So where do our
drugs come in?
Right here.
The NSAIDs block
cyclooxygenases and
therefore they inhibit
the synthesis of the
prostagnoid signaling
molecules. These
are called
cycloendoperoxides. Here's our
PG2, PGG2, and our
PGH2 intermediates.
Okay, what does
cyclooxygenase look like
now? Well, this is some
illustrator's concept
based on study results
of the protein.
Arachidonic acid,
which is the substrate,
accesses the catalytic
sites in cyclooxygenase,
and I'll call
them COX, within
the hydrophobic channel.
This is a hydrophobic
channel, this is a
hydrophobic channel, and
the substrate binding
site is indicated
here on these figures.
So let's talk
about the different
functions of
the two types of
enzymes, the
COX-1 and COX-2.
COX-1 is primarily
producing
constitutively
active prostanoids.
And the term that's
frequently used to
describe the function
of these prostanoids
is housekeeping
functions. Basically,
these prostanoids, the
baseline prostaglandin,
prostacycline, etc.,
provide homeostatic
functions, keeping
our body in balance.
So, there is a
constant baseline
activity with the
prostanoids produced
by COX-1. A big
general overview.
COX-2 now, this
is inducible.
Inducible by the various
triggers that
we talked about.
And COX-2 will now
produce signaling
molecules that
are involved
with the inflammatory
response.
and it's a rapid
process, rapidly
upregulated in response
to inflammatory
stimuli and resulting
in inflammation,
pain sensitization,
and fever.
So to recap, COX-1
produces prostanoids
that are primarily
homeostatic in their
function, producing some
baseline activity, and
COX-2 are primarily
inducible in response
to an inflammatory
stimulus, and they in
turn produce inflammation,
pain, and fever.
So inflammatory
stimuli include some
cytokines here that
I mentioned, growth
factors, and
bacterial endotoxin.
now that said you may
have noticed i said
primarily we need to
remember that both cox-1
and cox-2 contribute
to the generation of
auto regulatory that's
these and homeostatic
prostanoids and both
can contribute to
the prostanoid formation
during inflammation
The body is fine
-tuned in such a way.
So arachidonic acid
will then enter
the hydrophobic
channel, the
catalytic site, bind
and be metabolized
to its various
prostanoids.
Good?
well now that we have
our prostanoids that
have been produced
remember that prostanoids
act only locally and
briefly they act on
their own cells that
secreted them and they
act on their close
neighboring cells so how
are they acting they go
out into the interstitium
and then they will
bind to specific
receptors. These are G
-protein coupled receptors.
You do understand
about these by now.
I am not asking you
to memorize these
receptors. I want
you to understand
the takeaway message
that prostanoids
have diverse actions
because of the
diverse and distinct
receptors. So we
know there are
different prostanoids
and they have their
specific, whoops,
specific receptor
types. Do you need
to memorize these?
No. You need to go
away with the takeaway
message. Diverse,
distinct receptors,
diverse effects.
Alright, we have to
talk about these various
functions. So we'll
begin with COX-1 derived
prostanoids, the
homeostatic functions.
Why do we need to
be looking at these?
Because the NSAIDs are
going to be blocking
prostanoid synthesis
everywhere that they
get to, which is
basically everywhere. So
I put Another takeaway
here at the top,
NSAID use can disrupt
the protective
homeostatic functions
of prostanoids
leading to
potentially serious
adverse effects in
at-risk individuals.
And we'll talk about
what that means.
Several NSAIDs
are available
without a prescription.
people treat themselves.
So when you're taking
a history from the
patient, be sure to
ask what medications
they're taking and
include the over-the
-counter medications
by specific names.
Allow them to
tell you and
then ask them
specifically.
All right.
So what are
some homeostatic
functions that
are going on?
protection of our
GI tract. So what
does this mean?
These two, PGE2
and PGI2, PGI2
is prostacycline,
PGE2 mainly stimulates
mucus and bicarbonate
secretion. So mucus to
protect our intestinal
lining, bicarbonate,
to counteract acid.
Both are involved
in maintaining
the mucosal blood flow.
PGE2 is involved
in reducing acid
secretion. So we get
that complementary
activity of
stimulating mucus and
bicarbonate
secretion at the same
time as decreasing
acid secretion.
And additionally,
we can't forget that
these prostanoids are
involved with repair,
epithelial repair
and turnover.
Okay, now imagine NSAID
use, regular NSAID
use. What is it
going to do to this
function, to this
cytoprotective function of
the intestine? It's
going to inhibit it.
What could result?
Well,
gastrointestinal tract
abrasions, ulcers,
bleeding, even
perforation.
Going now to platelet
function. Platelet
function is modulated
by thromboxane A2.
That's it, thromboxane
A2. This is a
COX-1-derived
prostanoid in platelets.
When thromboxane is
released from activated
platelets, it will
promote platelet
activation and enhance
any platelet activation
that's there. and
it will cause local
vasoconstriction.
So why of these two
things? Remember, this
is a local action.
The platelets are
sticking together and
at the same time,
the vessel is
constricting in order
to make that platelet
plug. And this is a
homeostatic process
because platelets get
activated and make
these plugs wherever
they may be needed and we
may not even be aware
that it's happening.
What happens if we block
this with an NSAID?
Increased risk
of bleeding, no.
Because we're
inhibiting that
platelet plugging effect.
Kidneys, very
important. We have to
be thinking about
the effect of these
drugs on our
delicate glomerular
function, our delicate
kidney function.
Again, we see
PGE2 and PGI2.
Vasodilation of the
afferent arteriole.
That's the one that goes
into the glomerulus.
Maintenance of the
glomerular
filtration rate.
If we squeeze off that
afferent arteriole,
then that's going
to reduce the
pressure within the
glomerulus because
there's less blood
going into it, and
that's going to
reduce the glomerular
filtration rate. And
if it's bad enough,
that could lead to
acute kidney injury.
What else is happening
there in the kidney?
These prostanoids
promote sodium
and water excretion.
So that's all
part of managing
kidney function.
And this is our
homeostatic effect.
Again, our baseline
regulation of renin
release. And renin
is an enzyme that
leads eventually to
the formation of a
vasoconstrictor
called angiotensin II.
What happens if we
put our NSAIDs into
it, especially in
people who take them
regularly and are
already at risk because
they have reduced
kidney function?
so we forget that
auto regulatory
vasodilation and that can
lead to vasoconstriction
which can lead
to a decrease in
glomerular filtration
rate and if it's enough
it can lead to acute
kidney injury if
we block sodium and
water excretion we
get sodium and water
reabsorption so what
does that do? That
increases blood volume
and that will increase
blood pressure.
And renin release is a
topic for another day.
All right.
These drugs do cross
the blood-brain
barrier and they
are involved
in CNS activities,
which I'm not
going to go into
in too much detail.
I will definitely
be going into these.
Immune system, while it's
involved in the
immune system
regulation, I
will be talking
about prostaglandin D2.
The takeaway here
is this is from the
mast cells. Now if
you think about mast
cells, think about
histamine release. Think
about the mediators
that come out of
the mast cell and
promote inflammation.
Vascular tone.
What's here
again? PGE2, PGI2.
Basal hemodynamics to
support blood pressure.
Contribute to the
basal vasodilation.
Counteract excessive
vasoconstriction.
And support
the endothelial
homeostasis.
endothelial balance.
And what about the
reproductive organs?
PGF2 alpha we think
of with uterine
smooth muscle. It
causes contraction.
So when do we
think about uterine
contractions,
menstrual cycle,
and in labor.
The PGF2-alpha is
highly upregulated at
the time of labor and
it will cause that
uterine contraction
and other functions.
Bottom line NSAID
use can disrupt the
protective homeostatic
functions of the
prostanoids, leading
to potentially
serious adverse
effects in patients who
are already vulnerable
to these effects.
COX-2 derived now.
Remember, COX-2 is
primarily inducible, and
those prostaglandins
and prostanoids are
involved in inflammation,
pain, and fever.
All right. Let's
take a look
at this now. Here's
our prostanoid.
This is prostaglandin E2,
causing vasodilation,
vascular permeability,
immune modulation,
and tissue repair and
regeneration. We are
going to be blocking
that with our NSAIDs.
PGE2 is the major
pain causer, major
nociceptor sensitizer,
and PGE2 is the
primary fever
mediator acting in the
hypothalamus, and
that raises the body's
temperature set point.
We are blocking that.
Well, fever makes
sense to use an NSAID.
NSAIDs are for
fever reduction.
Pain.
Well, Well it makes
sense to use an NSAID.
NSAIDs help
reduce the pain.
Inflammation. It
makes sense to use it
for inflammation
because NSAIDs reduce
inflammation. Are you
seeing a pattern here?
Prostacyclin,
vasodilation, vascular
permeability, immune
modulation. You
see why they work
together so often.
It is also
involved in pain.
It's not the
major nociceptor
sensitizer, but
it's involved.
PGD2, this is
derived from mast
cells, and this
is a COX-2-derived
prostaglandin. It is
involved with allergic
inflammation, mast
cell, and mast cell
mediators. usually mast
cells are activated
by antibodies some
pain this isn't
isn't certainly isn't
the major one and
thromboxyne a2 it's just
got these two functions
vasoconstriction
platelet activation
how easy is that okay
what's the pattern?
Therapeutic uses here.
COX-1 inhibition,
adverse effects.
So let's check
the knowledge.
I invite you to
pause the video and
look at these and
see if you can
remember on your
own, just for fun.
What membrane
derived fatty acid is
the precursor of
the prostanoids?
Right,
arachidonic acid.
Where in the cell is
the precursor located?
Right,
it's in the lipid
bilayer membrane,
the phospholipids,
that make up the
nuclear endoplasmic
reticulum complex.
What is the process
that converts the
precursor into the five
biologically active
prostanoids, the
coccyx. They convert
arachidonic acid to
PGG2 and PGH2, so it's
a two-step process,
which is then converted
to the biologically
active prostanoids
by prostanoid-specific
synthase enzymes.
And what are the
five prostanoids?
Well, first of all,
the prostanoids
are a subclass of
the large family of
eicosanoid signaling
molecules derived
from arachidonic
acid and, by the way,
other 20-carbon
fatty acids.
So the prostaglandins are
PGE2, PGF2-alpha, PGD2.
The other prostanoids
are PGI2, which
is prostacyclin,
and thromboxane A2.
what determines whether
certain prostanoids
are constitutively
expressed or inducible
and always define the
terms well constitutive
expression is an enzyme
in our case today
or a receptor that
remains in an active
state meaning always
on without requiring a
stimulus so that's going
to produce that basal
level inducible
expression and enzyme or
receptor as we have
learned that is activated
only in response to
a specific stimulus.
So COX-1 is
constitutively active
producing these basal
level prostanoids to
provide the homeostatic
functions and
you'll hear about
it so often as being
referred to as
housekeeping functions.
PGE2, PGI2 are
widely expressed. I
think you saw that
in a previous slide.
COX-2 is inducible,
rapidly inducible, in
response to inflammatory
stimuli such as
TNF-alpha, interleukin
-1, growth factors,
bacterial endotoxin,
producing prostanoids
involved in inflammation,
pain, and fever.
Please remember
both COX-1 and COX-2
contribute to
the generation of
autoregulatory and
homeostatic prostanoids
and both can contribute
to prostanoid
formation during
inflammation.
How do the prostanoids
exert their
different effects
in various tissues.
They're autocrine and
paracrine molecules,
meaning they bind their
specific G protein
coupled receptors on
their own cells that
secrete them and on
their close neighboring
cells that they can
diffuse to and that
will activate the
intracellular signal.
Cells express specific
prostanoid receptors
according to their
physiologic functions.
And that concludes
the biochemistry
and physiology of
the arachidonic acid
metabolism and
prostanoid synthesis.